blonde and the brunette it was girls
night out for The Real Housewives of New
York City Wednesday as LuAnn Dorinda and
Ramona hit up Daily Mail's unwrap the
holidays party lots of fun we're a
discombobulated housewives family in the
same job we are family you know what I
mean because it's a housewives family so
it's like a weird you know we'll always
be we actually really enjoy each other's
company I mean it goes for the left some
time but we definitely go to the left
but we have a lot of good time so much
this was one of Luann's first big public
outings since her divorce from Tom
D'Agostino was finalized in October I'm
not really dating I'm taking time for
myself I'm enjoying my children and my
girlfriend my fact you know I'm getting
my life back I'm getting you know
looking for an apartment in the city so
I'm just trying to get back on my feet
but that's so I don't have time for you
know but I'm done to me your eyes are
closed I'm looking I look around saw
quick head turns is room and have a look
the stairs so she's still alive game
[Music]